beth rigby is here with me now so beth
how this all pans out all depends on
what is going on behind us right here
right now
there are a number of cabinet ministers
in there right now uh the chief whip
chris heaton harris is in there we also
know that sir graham brady uh who is the
chair of the 1922
uh back bench committee he basically is
the envoy of all the back benches has
also gone in uh via the cabinet office
we didn't walk up the street and we know
that there are
at least half a dozen
half a dozen cabinet ministers who are
in there as a delegation to tell boris
johnson that they think now is the time
for him to resign and if he doesn't then
they will leave his government that he
has lost their confidence but there's
also other cabinet ministers in there
nadine dorrie's for sure who is in there
to back boris johnson up so there's
cabinet ministers in there
and some division and dermot
i honestly tonight at the moment
what will boris johnson do you know he
has said repeatedly
all the time that i've interviewed him
in recent weeks about his future and his
fate he's very clearly repeated in the
comments today
i have been given a colossal mandate he
would say i have been given the support
of 14 million voters in 2019 i was the
most successful prime minister of the
ballot box for the conservatives since
the days of margaret thatcher and you
guys are not going to force me out my
mandate is via the public not by you
so you know in his heart his instinct
will be to fight to the very end so it
would have to have i mean just sort of
interject there but of course if he
fights the very end as it stands now
what we know you know we're only
imagining what might be taking place in
there and as you say we can't know but
what we do know is the number of
ministerial resignations that took place
today you cannot function as the prime
minister without a government no but he
might i don't know he might say i'm not
going to resign bring it on force this
confidence that you have to force me out
now that would go against all convention
i mean if the if you end up with you
know a sizable chunk if not the majority
of your cabinet quietly tapping on your
shoulder saying you've lost the
confidence of the cabinet you've lost
the confidence of the parliamentary
party you've lost 38
mps from your government you actually
can't run your government you can't run
the country at that point most prime
ministers would say the game's up i've
got to go but you know i i can't predict
uh what boris johnson will do all i can
tell you is what i have seen in his mind
which was a fierce determination come
what made to carry on which is why how
this plays out tonight will be so
interested in what he decides to do in
the coming hours so if it does come down
to the 1922 committee as i described
there you know they're changing the
committee their elections to the
committee they could then change the
rules and perhaps hold a vote sometime
next week if they do change those rules
is there another way that that could be
speeded up if graham brady has gone in
there the chair of the committee and
said well look you know i've already got
these letters coming through prime
minister they're in the hundreds now or
whatever plus the number of resignations
you've had from your ministerial ranks
you presumably voted for your last time
the game's up yeah you're quite right
dumb i mean what graham buried he can do
is go in and say to the prime minister
look i've got a parliamentary majority
have sent me letters saying uh that he
wants the pm um
to resign that they want the prime
minister to resign and graham brady
could show the evidence and say i can
tell you
you will be forced out in a confidence
vote unless you resign um so i'm just
i'm a bit jumpy because i'm i'm kind of
looking around just to see
what's moving around but um
yes he
he could uh graham brady could just say
to him these are the facts you cannot
stay on you will be voted out and then
the cabinets say you have to resign
and at that point boris johnson will
have to take his decision but in terms
of the process of the 22 there was talk
earlier today before this sort of
crescendo really built with the
resignations
that they might try and force a rule
change uh
for next week or rule change now with a
vote next week or a vote even earlier
than that and actually tonight the
committee didn't decide to change the
rules they've just brought forward
the elections of a new executive they
were going to do that right before
recess
and they're going to do that next monday
so if he doesn't go in the next few days
at that point they could uh trigger a
vote but i have to say
it's hard to see how it comes to that
if
there is a mass walk out of the cabinet
and it's clear that he will lose that
vote but we'll have to see